Paul the world and time Doctor Who
series 10 episode 11 Wow
okay um spoilers spoilers spoilers
spoilers all the spoilers coming up I'm
gonna get pretty much my one and only
major criticism of this thing out of the
way because it is not the fault of this
episode and that is I really really wish
that the return of John Simm as the
master and to me more importantly the
presence of Monday and Cybermen had not
been known ahead of the airing of this
episode I wish that so much because
especially giving that the Mondas reveal
is literally in the last five minutes of
this episode I really really really wish
that I could have experienced that slow
realization that fans of classic Doctor
Who could have just started to realize
because first you would have just seen
you know that the stock he's over the
heads and maybe that wouldn't have been
enough later you see the the nose hosing
you start going wait a minute and then
when Missy mentions twin planet you go
oh my god that's what it should have
been and it wasn't because we had
already known the month - the inside
room we're coming back I mean even
before the next time on Doctor Who that
was at the tail end of the last episode
they you know we knew back in March it
got announced that the Mon dancing
Cybermen were coming back and I that's
not necessarily BBC's fault I'm sure
part of the reasons that they did at
they did that is the same reason that
they are probably never gonna do what I
really want them to do with the
regeneration which is to not tell us who
is cast and just to have the doctor
regenerate and we find out what happens
I don't expect that to ever happen
because this stuff is impossible to keep
quiet anymore there's too many ways it
can leak you know from the set if
nothing else even if you keep the
casting secret and everything else you
know from the set sight you know
somebody everybody has a phone in their
pocket somebody will snap a picture of
Yo Ma audacity and Cyberman you know
just
moving between sets something we would
have known so in an effort to not have
you know those sorts of things spoiled I
think they these sorts of things tend to
spoil them themselves just because they
figure it's inevitable anyway and I wish
that wasn't the case it kind of is but
setting that aside what's it's a really
really great episode there is there is
so much I love about the missile first
of all this is practically a doctor
light episode I mean he he barely
appears but it oh my god this is so I
don't even know where to start there's
so much I love about this all right
Missy I love the whole feel and vibe of
Missy trying to be the doctor the way
she says lines her attitude that you
still get that edge of danger I die
believe bill when bill says I'm scared
of her and yet at the same time she's
trying to do she's mockingly trying to
do the doctor I love that dynamic and I
I said it before and now I'm gonna wish
it all the more I wish that we could
have an almost a full series of Missy
and Capaldi her being his companion oh
god that would be so amazing and and
having it for this this one episode if
nothing else is awesome and fantastic
god I wish we were gonna get more of it
cuz so good what else okay Johnson first
of all um miss the character of mr.
razor I loved like pretty much
immediately I loved him I loved his way
of speaking his way of processing
information the little quirks of his
ways of sort of thinking and relaying
information I loved his dynamic with
bill loved all of that and I I didn't I
didn't see John Simm behind that then
you know the wrinkles and the beard and
that I didn't see him I didn't see him
at all like to the point I wait on line
and did a tiny bit of research and if
you know anything if you listen to my
podcast you know I hate research but I
wanted to confirm that was really him
right I wanted to confirm for sure
because I
felt like that could have been another
actor and he was just simple girl Hills
I know that was him my god and then like
I said the whole thing with the Montes
and the slow reveal as the pieces fall
into place again ruined by the fact that
we already knew it was gonna be mom -
but still holy cow and also would bill
oh man so when she blasted through the
chest they did and here's another thing
I thought one thing at the time that
initially happened and then and softened
on it so admission when she got blasted
through the chest I was like oh my god I
thought they might actually kill her
right then and there and actually I
think I'm not gonna say I necessarily
wish this this would happen like would
the next campaign or whatever but I
think at some point we need a companion
to die for lack of a better term on
spectacularly I think at some point we
need to lose a companion suddenly not
they know it's coming not it's a big
sacrifice not you know it's a decision
that they make or or you know whatever
just something goes wrong they're gone
and I thought we were gonna get this
with this now when she initially woke up
my first thought was oh you didn't have
the guts to go through with it but then
you know with the way you know her
dynamic with mr. racer and all that I
was loving that so much it was like I
will forgive you for not going through
with that and going with this cuz this
is really good and really cool and sort
of using her and this bring back the
Mondas Cybermen was something as a
concept I was interested in but also
somewhat cautious about because I was
afraid it was gonna be gimmicky but they
do such a good job of doing what that
very first incarnation of the Cybermen
did so well which is freaking creepy
they are so creepy and and just these
tiny little things like the fact that
the nurse goes and you think she adjusts
things so that that that prototype
Cyberman it isn't feeling pain anymore
and then you realized all she did was
turn down the volume so she doesn't have
to listen to the fact that he's in pain
anymore and and these these roundabout
solutions
these people these the manassas do
believe like we have to do this we
haven't we are going to die if we don't
do this and it will be a horrible
existence but we're gonna make the best
that we can out of it so this whole idea
of like here's this headpiece it won't
make the pain go away but you'll stop
caring about it so it's like we can't
actually make this existence anything
other than horrific but we can sort of
trick your brain into being okay with
how horrible this is going to be oh that
is so so creepy and and the land this
they were able to recreate that insanely
just creepy look and and the thing about
the mom that Cybermen originate easy it
is a bit of a hokey costume but there
was something so creepy and they updated
it just enough where it loses the ho
keenest but it kept all the creepy and
that and that's good because Cybermen
stories can be very up-and-down I think
they have one I was gonna say they had
been in the modern era I think they were
even with classic who they they really
could go either way they weren't always
the best stories and I think in some
ways the longer Cybermen stuck around
the less the show kind of knew what to
do with them and I think that happened
in the classic series I think we were
seeing that happen here but here they
went back to the basics they went back
to the original like this concept is
freakin creepy let's make it creepy
again and yes yes they did and there's
so many other just tiny little the whole
idea of the the time moving different
because one end of the ship is closer to
the black hole than the other that's
really clever that's awesome
I love that miss he called um nardole
and bill exposition and comic relief
just I'd love Missy I really really do I
spoke you know what aside from the the
fact that we already knew that Mondas
was gonna be turning up in this the one
other thing that I don't love was that
we opened on the doctor appearing to
regenerate I don't I just don't like
that as a storytelling device when a
story basically you know that has to
start slow or basically the first thing
they give you something that happens way
later basically be like
here's the exciting stuff that's coming
now here's our slower start it's like
you don't need to do that I'd and that's
that's just kind of me I don't like that
as a storytelling device and I actually
has a date to call it device is a
shortcut it's a cheat it's it's a very
transparent hook and I don't like it I
wish the show hadn't done it but again
that's like that's a tiny nitpick so
like my only issues are that and
something that is not the fault of this
episode it's just you know it's the
world of Doctor Who and the the release
of information but oh wow Wow now the
last time that a second last episode of
a series got me this excited was
heaven-sent and I can follow it up with
hell-bent so I'm really hoping they can
stick the landing on this one because
this is this is a really strong lead in
to a finale and I'm gonna be really
curious as to the logistics of how John
Simm as the master works and why
Missy doesn't room I figured we're gonna
get one of a couple things then we're
gonna have to account for some degree of
memory messing with or like some
something is gone wrong with time and
they're gonna have to integrate that so
I'm not sure what the cases I'm curious
as to the logistics of that I'm cautious
about how Johnson's gonna work because I
haven't seen some of my older videos I'm
kind of 50/50 on John Simm
I liked him much better when he came
back for the end of time than when he
was in series 3 with the sound of drums
last of the time I was I didn't like him
in that nearly as much so it's not clear
at this point which he's gonna lean more
towards if we haven't really seen enough
yet he's together enough that I have a
feeling it's gonna lean more towards
that original appearance but you know
again I don't want a knock John Simm
because you're not Simms mr. racer was
pretty awesome but I'm just sort of
expensive I am I like like I said this
is
oh good it makes me very nervous to see
the next episode because I'm like I'm
really afraid that you know when you've
got a first-half that's this good that
is really hard to stick the landing and
and have the the conclusion match what
you've already given us and I really
really really hope it does and yeah
we'll we'll see what happens holy cow
that was good that was really good so
what were your thoughts on world enough
in time whatever they were drop
something out in the comments let's talk
about it don't forget to like subscribe
check me out on Twitter at council of
geeks give a listen to the council of
geeks podcast I am also one half of
these punch like a girl podcast both of
those are available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is jernt
[Applause]